how's it going bros - this is the
greatest party of all time go in don't
be shy go in and dance welcome to dying
light this bill is exclusively for party
pie I've been shooting a little bit I've
been playing through the the prologue
and it's amazing it's been a while since
I've been this excited for a game this
game is just so cool but an option Chet
let me show you how cool it is I just
accepted it acquires called mother's day
should be interesting
hello chaps great shoes so sorry I'll be
on my way now
so we infiltrated this giant building we
are also infected but don't freak out we
have this thing called Alzheimer no wait
auntie auntie cyma auntie's i'ma which
makes you go zombie less fast also think
about this game if you didn't know ready
you're a freaking parkour boss look at
this because zombies can't climb very
well but we can out see just as I did oh
look there's one nice skirt - alright
this sneaky he thinks he's fabulous I oh
hey step [ __ ] shake that's my skirt
oh my god alcohol yeah that's right you
skank
the world is so open and it's so
immersive just look at this you should
see from the tower later I'll show you
it's so cool I don't even know what to
tell you bris oh god oh god what the
hell was that oh god what that is so
creepy oh damn it I hate when things
breaks it gives me a heart attack
why are we going oh god I think we have
to go through this tunnel no time for
chitchat sorry
oh god this is creepy hmm don't like
that place where's the house it's one of
these houses try here oh there we go
I was just about to say the same
chocolate no no wait a minute that's too
much nope no chocolate I gotta draw the
line there people say
oh my god I'm gonna guess mommy is dead
I don't know or I think he just really
wants to chocolate get the special box
of chocolate for each month all right I
can do it oh god damn it we have to go
back through the creepy tunnel survivors
inside that's awesome
Oh God nope those are not survivors
those are not survivors they're chasing
me ah damn it why me
Oh Rox hello this is it all right oh
well [ __ ] what am I supposed to say hi
guys
open please Hailee's I've got it great
it's not a new bra oh my god you look
great okay we restored power
oh god I'm an idiot hey fridge then
before breakfast you guys should join
the party - it's great it's a breakdance
it's a breakdance get out of the way
look how they're dancing it's amazing
this is the greatest party of all time
go in don't be shy go in and dance
that's right that's more like it Steve
what a fun party can I lift oh there it
is excuse me sir
I said excursion oh oh all right let's
find the damn chocolate it's unlocked
this oh that was difficult I like it I
like it a lot when they're challenged me
like that box of chocolate and some
coffee thank you I'll take that and I'll
take that and I'll take that yeah how
much coffee do I need I don't know let's
take this way out yeah we did it froze
so proud so proud
number one proud let's go and get the
other one yep horse oh of course
all right how where is the other way
around
lock-picking okay let's do this really
fast please oh god oh god they're coming
thank you
please open thank you Hey oh god oh god
yeah what was that
it's Charlie C for Charlie yes yes of
course
Charlie let's see latest found edger
best movie ever
totally worth almost getting killed for
all that moving this great love - oh my
god loved one was great but love - was
just a classic sorry are you guys
impressed by this game I I am [ __ ]
impressed can't wait to eat chocolate
and watch that my favorite movie I mean
gods that gauzy is that it's a gauzy
yeah I got your chocolate chocolate see
all this maze hey hey just let myself in
through the roof really
really what a jerk let's see if we can
do this job yeah no more HBO for you
[ __ ] enter through the roof they said
how the hell am I supposed to do that I
said oh hey how's it going
that I did the trick what a lovely
toilet he keeps it so clean I'm so
impressed guys hey are you here oh
that's my favorite film is this loved
one oh man what a lovely mom you have
may I sit down next to you wonderful
wonderful such beautiful mom I see where
you get your lovely features but from
medicine to help my friend okay pumpkin
yeah thanks gauzy thanks you're just
you're just a [ __ ] aren't you that
sounded wrong I'm sorry he has to love
to poster I know we share the game I
knew we share our movies favorite
tranquilizers thank you okay so the
reason we wanted a medicine it was to
get some make sure that the people in
the tower know that we're legit
oh god this place is terrifying oh nice
they made a little campfire that's
that's so cute I love campfires Hey Oh
Joe did you see that did you see that
that's amazing
hi ha ha oh my god oh my God look I mean
come on look at this how [ __ ] cool it
says this is what I wanted to show in
the beginning Jesus Christ that's so
awesome and there's just a medic here
you go Harry gasps he's great she's
happy I think she likes me
with his thanks hey five hundred packs
amp I can buy myself some chocolate
thank you and she called me a champion
hey hey she hitting on me and we did it
Mother's Day the best quest ever I post
unfortunately that's all I can show you
but I can keep playing how much I watch
sorry sorry Bruce what do you think
about this game are you excited as I am
I'll leave a link where you can
pre-order this game if you want sound in
the description and that's all for me
for now I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did leave a like and like
if you want me to do a full playthrough
of this when it comes out I think that
could be cool Rose thank you for
watching as always stay awesome dress